when I started this book I wanted to
figure out how to get some sense of how
the oil industry works and how it fits
together you know it's a very you can
anyone can go to a gas station you slide
your card the oil comes into your tank
the money goes out of your bank account
and you drive off and that's pretty much
it for the transaction so my task here
was to trace that transaction back all
the way along the supply chain and to
try to get a sense of you know how it
went together for individual people how
it goes together as an economy and what
are some of the questions that we don't
really ask as we go along the way a
couple of things came out I'll get to
reading a little bit for you but a
couple of things came out one is is that
consumers when they buy gas we're very
aware of price but we don't actually
respond to it we don't reduce the amount
of gas that we use when prices are high
we don't even reduce the amount of gas
that we use as much as our parents did
in the 1970s as gas prices doubled
people cut back their gasoline use by
about thirty percent which is pretty big
response now that the same thing has
happened over the past five years prices
have almost doubled and the response has
been as sort of a three percent pullback
of consumption and that has big
repercussions around the world you know
if you have a really big block of
consumers not really responding to price
we're kind of driving that price for the
world and it provides kind of a platform
for increasing prices part of the reason
we do that is because we're using credit
cards part of it is because we don't we
feel we can't conserve and part of it is
probably because we many people have
enough money where they don't have to
conserve the other what that trend means
is that the u.s. infrastructure is
actually filling up and we have very
little spare capacity in our pipelines
no spare capacity in our refineries and
that makes adds to another level of
volatility in prices
and then what we have is globally we
have of course increasing consumption in
China and India and increasing demand
for oil globally and very very tight
supplies are driven by some new
political considerations so I was going
to read to you a little bit from the
section on Venezuela in Venezuela since
the 20s there's been sort of a
competition between the people of
Venezuela the government of Venezuela
and what they see as the foreign oil
companies in the 70s the foreign oil
company became the Venezuelan oil
company and now the government and the
Venezuelan oil company are sort of in
competition for the same revenues from
the oil which the oil company would
prefer perhaps to invest in the ground
to increase their production and the
government would prefer to distribute in
some way to the people to create
essentially stability so I'm going to
read just a little bit about what that
competition for resources means in
Venezuela the Venezuelan oil company pet
of Asaph PDVSA has been spending a lot
of money recently on social programs to
support the Chavez government in 2004
the company announced that it had spent
4.35 billion on social spending and only
3 billion on oilfield investments that
has big implications for those of us who
depend upon them increasing their oil
investments in increasing their oil
output it's possible to imagine a future
where the internal politics of petroleum
have eclipsed the current logic of the
oil market and Venezuela oil market oil
exports to the United States trickle off
ever since the very first days of the
oil age in the 1860s periods of high oil
prices have been followed by investment
binges which put more oil on the market
and lowered prices but in Venezuela the
state and the oil company are in
competition for the same scarce
resources and as long as political
instability around the world keeps oil
prices high and of course there's strong
demand there's no pressing need to
invest
by 2006 there were even rumors that pedo
vases oil production had fallen off so
dramatically that the company was buying
oil from Russia to fulfill its long-term
contracts most forecasts call for a huge
increase in OPEC oil production in the
next 20 years one estimate says the
world needs to invest 16 trillion
dollars in energy supplies by 2030 to
keep up with demand these production
projections don't take into account the
fact that OPEC production has fallen
since 1978 like Venezuela many Petro
states have been reluctant to invest
money in oil production or to accept
foreign funding Kuwait for example has
planned to let international oil
companies invest in increasing its oil
production since 1997 but the details of
the deal have gotten bogged down and in
a parliament fearful of foreign
intervention high prices have made the
oil even more useful politically in 2005
ally Robert Rodriguez Araki he moved
from the head of ped of ASA to become
Venezuela's foreign minister engaging in
a constant roster of petrol diplomacy
what started as trading oil for Cuban
doctors and then for Argentina's beef
became much more ambitious later that
year he told me this is ally Rodriguez
Araki told me that oil is an economic
and social force in the country but it
also has a political component the link
between sovereignity and oil is very
strong he said in 2006 Venezuela
expanded its political reach even
covering 2.5 billion of Argentina's debt
the country was selling oil at a
discount everywhere from New York's
Bronx - poor residents hurt by high oil
prices to the Caribbean and Uruguay
Chavez was creating common interests
among Venezuela Argentina Bolivia cuba
nicaragua Ecuador Chile and Brazil with
raids of oil pipelines and influence he
was also sponsoring Telesur a TV channel
that aims to be a spanish-language
al-jazeera further abroad the country is
using oil to cement deals with China and
Iran Chavez was quoted as saying that
Venezuela quote has a strong card to
play on the geopolitical stage is a card
that we are going to play with toughness
against the toughest country in the
world the United States
Chavez may have been playing cards but
the United States still prefers to think
that the game is as it has always been
a simple exchange between a big country
with a lot of money in a small country
with a lot of oil the cost of oil in the
United States is confined to the numbers
on the pump not to its intangible
politics and as Petro state politics
proved more and more pricey in terms of
both the cost of crude and the
insecurity of the supply the US will
have fewer options another place that I
went that sort of confounds the sort of
traditional concept of oil supply and
national competition for oil is China as
you know China is now the world's second
largest oil importer it's grown just
dramatically in terms of influence in
the past five years but one of the
things that we don't oftentimes realize
is that China actually imports a million
barrels of oil a day on our behalf which
they then used to make everything from
ceramic toilets to deck chairs and then
we import so we are actually importing
an extra million barrels a day of oil
through China which makes it so that
when if we think of ourselves purely in
competition with China we actually
really need to revise that picture I'll
read a little bit about China's auto
industry in the way that they're
thinking about the future which I found
quite provocative and has also has great
implications for how the US needs to
kind of rethink its oil policy or its
energy policy and think towards the
future because China obviously will be a
competitor a helper it'll be everything
Mao famously said that the revolution
that revolution occurs only at the end
of a gun but a revolution is happening
now in China at the wheel of a car as
millions of Chinese start driving the
effects of this revolution and personal
mobility are being felt in the oil
market where Chinese oil consumption has
risen 45% in the last five years in
geopolitics and at home in China where
it's challenging the leadership of the
Communist Party but that's only the
beginning of the revolution because now
China is also making the cars for the
past century cars have been a
quintessentially American thing Perdue
for the big and growing US market and
exported to people who wanted to adopt
the American lifestyle but the US market
is now so saturated the only way to sell
more cars is to lower the driving age we
actually have 1.07 cars per American
registered driver now so we're kind of
saturated the next big market is in
China which has the same number of cars
per capita as the United States did in
1910 and that means that the future here
the future is here in China where the
car is starting its second life in 2000
there were 16 million cars in China
today there are about 33 million and by
2010 there may be 56 million and that
all may double again by 2020 to 120
million one person said to me when a car
becomes something everyone can afford
forget it you won't be able to drive in
1992 trying to export it oil but one
year later it started importing and each
year since 1993 it's needed more China
sees its need for oil both as a
strategic challenge and as a business
opportunity in 2005 they said about
signing long term supply contracts all
over the world in Iran it promised a 70
70 billion dollars in an auto assembly
plant in Nigeria three billion and a
refinery Saudi Arabia Kazakhstan Russia
Canada Ecuador Angola Chad Syria one of
the Chinese national companies tried to
buy the American company unocal but was
blocked by an indignant Congress but
China has made it clear that it was more
it was more interested in getting oil in
just doing business than in getting
involved in the politics of oil
producers it was in a sense history
repeating itself in the 1940s the United
States took over Britain's old oil
concessions claiming it would just do
business and now it's China's turn I met
with a bureaucrat who's at the the think
tank that consults with the Communist
Party he started off by telling me that
he didn't like cars I object to this
vague notion of status he said laughing
a bit at himself more seriously he said
people worry that promoting the American
Way of life could create a disaster in
China
it doesn't really matter how he feels
about the cars because they're here to
stay he starts out by laying out the
numbers that govern his job China's
projected population peak of 1.5 billion
in 2030 requires continuing GDP growth
of 8 or 9 percent per year and because
China's industry is inefficient it
requires massive amounts of energy in
2005 China's oil imports rose by 16%
faster than GDP oil imports alone will
need to quadruple by 2020 this is what
he says there is no hope of lessening
energy requirements until 2100 when the
population will drop below a billion
I've never heard an American planner
talk in these timeframes of a hundred
years and it's a bit thrilling oil has
become the second most important issue
for the government economists right
after food he explains the urgency
without strict controls China's growth
will be choked by the lack of energy and
because the country is not as efficient
as say Japan it requires four or five
times much energy for a single point of
GDP
if the GDP doesn't grow there will be
unemployment and unrest so energy is
directly related to the stability and
the governments hold on power and till
late in the century the other aspect of
that is that as GDP Rises the pollution
is actually choking back 15 to 20
percent of GDP at from time to time it's
that those numbers are kind of shaky but
they understand that they need to manage
the pollution at the same time that they
manage the GDP growth or else they'll be
colliding so what's happened is is that
they've adopted efficiency as a strategy
and they've also taken some big steps
towards alternate fuels with a different
sort of strategy than the u.s. in 2004
China shook the automakers worldwide
with the incredible speed and strictness
of the auto fuel efficiency standards
that enacted enacted which are five to
ten percent stricter than the u.s.
standards and among the roughest in the
world I actually went to meet the people
who had made the statistic the the new
standards but I won't read about that
part there was a bigger strategy behind
the rules than merely saving fuel and
preventing pollution the ultimate intent
of the regulations was to make Chinese
built car
more exportable to high-end markets such
as Europe the regulations were designed
to pressure joint ventures like GM and
Volkswagen to send their newest
technology to China and the standards
are part of the slow revolution that
could make China the new Detroit when
the Chinese bureaucrats in charge of the
standards listen to Detroit auto
executives denigrate fuel economy
standards China actually sent a
delegation of bureaucrats from the
Ministry of Standards to on a tour of
the US which involves stops in Detroit
to talk to people about fuel-efficient
Stann fuel efficiency standards but when
they heard the the executives denigrate
fuel economy standards they heard an
opportunity they perceived Detroit's
reluctance as a strategic weakness and a
clear way for China's industry to become
more competitive this is a quote from a
consultant who worked with them China
doesn't subscribe to the idea that
what's good for GM is good for the
country they've gone on this very
ambitious plan - as you know they have
GDP targets but they also now have fuel
efficiency targets and one of their
goals originally was to replace 10% of
China's energy use with renewable
sources by 2020 with the final aim of
reducing oil imports to just 6% of
consumption but by late 25 2005 the
target shifted upward now the country
was going to get 15% of its energy from
renewables by 2020 and in early 2006
Premier Wen Jiabao announced that energy
efficiency was a new economic marker and
he expected China's energy use per unit
of GDP to start falling by 4% a year
what this is meant on a local level is
that local technology Institute's are
coming up with all sorts of wild and
wonderful cars and they're really
rethinking the car there's an ambitious
program involving hydrogen that's run on
absolute shoestring there are programs
involving hydrogen buses and hybrid
buses one of the interesting models that
they use is building things much cheaper
with sort of fewer capabilities one one
program in Beijing on hydrogen buses
uses much less hydrogen and
is much cheaper than the competitive
DaimlerChrysler Chrysler bus but its top
speed is 35 miles an hour which is
obviously perfectly appropriate for a
beijing street but it's not the way that
the Western companies are building their
their hydrogen equipment this is
actually a strange little electric car
I'm going to read about that was built
by a sort of out-of-the-way Technical
College in Wuhan they brought this car
to a a worldwide rally that was held in
in Shanghai called bibendum that's run
by the Michelin Corporation and all the
biggest car companies in the world bring
their sort of most forward-thinking
alternative fuel vehicles there I see a
bizarre little yellow car shaped like an
egg in front there are seats for two
behind a window shaped like ski goggles
viewed head-on the headlights and the
motor cover make a big cartoonish eyes
with a grin car as smiley face I feel
silly grinning back at it in back
there's a cute shelf like a very
abbreviated truck bed with rocket shaped
taillights so to think about it it was
kind of like a little egg with this
miniature shelf on the back and the
whole thing was a little bit bigger than
this table and and kind of wide the
people who made the car are students
from the Wuhan Institute of Technology
and they're hanging out in a giddy
little circle near the car one runs to
get their professor the name of the car
is the Aspire they say because it's the
spirit the student designer a sincere 21
year old in a white shirt says the car
is designed to attract young bloods and
new white colors which is how he
characterizes the aspiring global middle
class that vast crowd who was just
getting enough money to think about
buying a car but whose hopes are
constrained by traffic pollution and
potential fuel shortages car owners make
up about 12% of the world's population
the aspire is for the other 88 percent
and that's who they see as their market
the professor shows up and explains that
the crew made the two prototypes with
just $60,000 and three months of
sleeping in their classroom
she flops down in the shelf on the back
of the tool it'll car what's that for I
asked
a bike or a rowboat is the answer why
because everyone who drives in China can
expect to be caught in traffic jams so
they would use the bike to continue
their commute and the rowboat the idea
of putting a rowboat on the back is for
weekend outings which they are expecting
that that's part of the being middle
classes that you have these outings on
the weekends they have essentially made
a concept car for traffic jams it has a
target price of twelve thousand dollars
it's an electric vehicle so it doesn't
add to the smog onboard GPS helps
identify traffic snarls in advance
allowing our future driver to park the
doors open upward so it can fit into
very very tight spaces and can they can
continue to work with that onboard
bicycle if they are caught in traffic
they can plug in to the car's CPU which
is a Linux based operating system
instead of an instrument panel the car
just has a LCD computer screen because
it's cheaper and it has no dashboard
which makes the space inside feel more
like a room than a car actually it
doesn't drive particularly well and it
made a horrible yelling noise as we
drove it and one of the engineers
shouted to me it has a few problems but
it has a happy feeling which was
basically kind of encapsulate this
vision of trying everything and trying
it really on a shoestring and trying to
really rethink the role of the car or
what it is at a rally showcasing an
idealized future for autos one of as GM
puts it no compromises the aspire is all
compromises it's slow speed small size
and agreeable demeanor wouldn't go down
in Detroit in the United States cars
have been about getting away from it all
and the Aspire is all about getting
along what I really love about sitting
in the Aspire is its lack of nostalgia
it's a car so involved in the future
it's lost all attachment to the ideas of
the past I don't know how are we doing
on time should time for a little bit
more okay I found that vision kind of
inspiring I also was very intrigued I
spent time in a refinery and the
refineries
one thing about people who work in the
oil industry is they're not particularly
optimistic you might expect them to be
optimistic but they're they're not they
spend a lot of time looking at
spreadsheets and figuring out managing
risk I mean I think in addition to
producing oil and getting it to our
tanks with incredible speed and
efficiency and and some profits the oil
industry is really about managing risk
and they spend they have huge staffs
that just spend a lot of time thinking
about risk and I found that to be quite
intriguing because it kind of suggests a
way forward for us as consumers we don't
think about risk we just go and fill up
but as we look towards the future we
really kind of need to assemble sort of
a giant spreadsheet and figure out the
risks we're willing to assume and the
risks were not willing to assume so this
is just a little bit about how this
refinery which was a bp's carson plant
in southern california looked at risk it
was talking to an engineer named ken ken
sometimes refers to the refinery as the
beast and he talks about the spreadsheet
with the phrase there's a tool for
optimizing the beast hmm one of the
issues that refineries are dealing with
is that good light oil has become very
has become relatively scarce and
expensive so there's a huge you can make
quite a lot of profit if you can use the
lower quality sulfurous salty sticky
heavy oil but you need to install extra
equipment to be able to process that so
good light oil has become scarce and
expensive but Sulphurs heavy oil is
plentiful and selling at a discount of
as much as $15 a barrel less than the
premium changing from the good oil to
the cheaper oil cannot be done quickly
or thoughtlessly you need equipment to
remove the sulfur and salt and here's
Ken talking over the past over the last
few years we've been pushing the
boundaries on Arab Croods the salt makes
thin metals in the refining unit and you
have to go in and fix them these cheaper
high sulfur crews will be even more
plentiful in the future so being able to
process them is a competitive advantage
but this is a challenge you have to
understand the boundaries and
manage the tension says ken without
action you pay big and that I think is
the watchword of the refineries they
spend a lot of time thinking about what
action they need to do now to avoid
paying big to prepare for a future of
heavy crudes the refinery is replacing a
50 year old vacuum tower the old tower
broke apart heavy oil but always ended
up with a large quantity of sludgy
leftovers that had to be sold as cheap
fuel the new tower will use a vacuum
filled with hot steam to crack the long
sludgy molecules into shorter chains of
gas oil which can then be referred
refined into gasoline or diesel Ken
shows me the site where workers are
crawling around in a five-story scaffold
welding large rings of steel into a tall
chamber the old tower or the new tower
excuse me will create an extra six
thousand barrels per day of gas oil from
the same amount of crude bringing the
refinery profits of fifty million
dollars a year and paying for itself
within possibly two years ringing more
oil from every barrel ringing more from
every barrel of oil as a national trend
the amount of oil products coming out of
American refineries now exceeds the
amount of crude going in by more than a
million barrels a day a phenomenon
called processing gain processing gain
shows how innovation can reduce the need
for more crude oil refiners however have
to make big investments like the vacuum
cleaner the vacuum tower sorry to
increase processing gained a report by
the McKinsey Global Institute in I think
was released in late November early
December said that the worldwide the
potential for increasing processing gain
is about four million barrels of oil a
day which is really quite huge when you
consider that the worldwide demand right
now is about 80 million barrels so but
the question is how to encourage
refiners to make those investments and
to some extent changing economic
realities will encourage that but there
may also be a role for regulation and
this is where things also get
interesting another profitable trick is
to turn the cheap products into
expensive ones carson sells coke it's a
sort of a giant charcoal briquette
that's a byproduct of processing the oil
they at the moment they sell them to
china cheaply managers want to find a
way to make the coke into some
thing more expensive and they wanted to
take advantage of California's plan to
limit greenhouse gases and let producers
trade credits so the Carson VP's Carson
Plant came up with a plan to actually
produce electricity from the coke and
also produce hydrogen which they would
then either recycle back into the
refinery or would potentially sell
outwards then they would take the co2
pressurize it and shove it back in the
oil fields that are close to them in
Long Beach so they would be pressing it
pushing it down deep underground
probably within within capped fields
obviously this is all rather new and
cutting edge technology the plant is
going to cost about a billion dollars by
pumping the greenhouse gasses into the
nearby old oil reservoirs not only would
they store them out of sight but they
would also increase the flow of oil
coming out of the wells and when trading
in greenhouse gas credit starts the
company will be positioned to make more
money this is more expensive but the
economics of trading gases could make it
worthwhile Ken says bp's project is an
interesting model of how environmental
regulation might be good for business
the politics of greenhouse gases in the
united states made similar government
projects low expensive and tinged by
futility
bp's power plant is bigger faster and
privately funded why should the taxpayer
pay a billion dollars for FutureGen
which is a government project in federal
clean coal when BP will spend that on
this project says Dave sim Beck a
consultant with SFA Pacific who believes
that the BP project could turn a profit
and be a model for disposing of
greenhouse gases there seems to be a
disconnect it is much better to create
incentives so business finds the
solution
I asked Ken what he was going to do when
greenhouse gases were limited was it
going to be a big burden co2 is a
spreadsheet item he said it becomes just
another economic factor it's just
another variable in your decisions and
you can put a number on it and financial
eyes it for me this was the lesson of
the refinery with fuel you'll always end
up paying whether it's higher prices at
the pump or more pollution or more
uncertainty the big question is who paid
I find Ken's vision strangely comforting
because it suggests that consumers could
make rational choices to prepare or
optimize our own
least four five ten and twenty years in
the future but will we when Ken talks
about things where things are going he's
not optimistic it'll need a step change
to really change behavior that's the
dilemma the world's got right do we just
continue as we go on until it becomes
infeasible or do we do something and
that's the end of my reading thank you
we talked about this before in fact your
last reading underscores as an economist
we have this notion of the right prices
are out there in the market everybody's
going to be responding magically almost
guided by an invisible hand to produce
this wonderful outcome that's impossible
worlds again the idea is that if we pay
the right prices everybody's going to be
guided by that pricing decision and as
if pushed by an invisible hand
we'll have this wonderful outcome the
best of all possible worlds and yet many
of the items in the book suggest that
maybe we may need more what I call the
theory the invisible foot the market
every now and then needs a swift kick to
remind it there may be better directions
more opportunities and we're generally
looking at so my question to you is and
building off of this last part of your
your book here what thoughts might you
have on taking this next step forward
that might really provide the market and
consumers with a better signal or
indication of what they might be able to
do it's it's an interesting thing this
invisible hand I I set out with a great
deal of faith in it when I first was
hanging out in the gas station but was
surprised to find that along the oil
economy there are very interesting
inefficiencies that are built in some
are legacies from the very start of the
refinery industry around the turn of the
century some are sort of left over from
other other moments of upheaval you know
it's interesting that
refineries aren't all investing in new
technology to give them the capacity to
invest it to create more fuel to sell
with by using less feedstock and it
seems like there needs to be government
policies that will work towards that it
also seems that consumers themselves
can't really they're not really
responding to prices in the last five
years the estimates are that they spent
an extra trillion dollars on energy
costs in the United States which is just
an enormous amount of money and some of
the energy that we use is kind of
buttressed by old policies one in
particular is that we do it we really
encourage supply both in we encourage
energy supply both at a tax level and at
certain political levels and what we
might do and what I think we should do
is really start to manage demand and
kind of give incentives to people for
using less fuel and one of those ideas
that we've talked about some at new
America and I've talked about some ones
with skip is an idea of sort of making
efficiency credits tradable so in effect
capping the amount of energy the
different segments of the economy use
and then letting those agents for
example utilities or car manufacturers
or lenders or insurers or large
companies trade efficiency as well the
in the similar way to the way that they
trade energy at this point but that's
kind of a that's a different idea out
there yes the kinds of efficiencies that
they're looking for in China to the
United States you mentioned very much in
passing hydrogen and then you spent some
time talking about electric vehicles
that's very interesting but there's no
interest in China and ethanol for
example or interest in ethanol biofuels
okay could you just talk a little
there's the maybe the dissimilarities
between the efficiency directions in
China
and here or are the similarities
whatever I mean well I think what's
interesting about about China is that
they're seeing efficiency as a they're
seeing it essentially as a fuel and as a
component of their GDP and as a way of
managing the risk of their growing GDP
so that's really interesting but they
actually are they're kind of throwing
everything at the problem including the
kids the kitchen sink I mean there's
just huge numbers of experimental energy
programs in China everything from using
kind of manure gas to cook food to
cycling air underground in Beijing for
both heating and cooling to making
regulations so that the bureaucrats at
official functions should not be wearing
coats during the summer and should be
wearing sweaters during the winter so
there's a you know a broad variety of
things but when you talk about the
different the alternative fuels they
also have an interesting sort of stepped
approach to alternative fuels we tend to
think of hydrogen as a separate category
and electric as a separate category they
see and we also think of hybrids and
natural gas vehicles as separate they
actually see the these four things on a
continuum and they essentially they look
at a hydrogen car as an electric car
that runs on sort of a hydrogen battery
so any improvement that you make an
electric cars or in hybrids makes a more
efficient hydrogen car if they ever
happen
you mentioned earlier that there's more
stringent environmental requirements for
mobiles
I wonder if you can elaborate a little
bit on that one most interested in is
where we say that American
and European manufacturers are
responding
are they or are they trying to
those standards there
when the standards first came out some
of the American and American
manufacturers in particular were
objected to them and said that they
intended to fight them but the the sort
of carrot of China's massive market is
so huge and American manufacturers make
more money selling car individual cars
in China than they do in the US so many
of them have kind of I think stepped up
to the plate but the one issue in China
is that the central government can set
regulations but then they don't
necessarily follow through for example
some cities in the south
made regulations saying that cars had to
have a certain length wheelbase because
they wanted to have mostly larger cars
on the streets and they weren't
interested in the the the Chinese
efficiency standards actually make
incentives for smaller cars so you have
these sort of you have pushes and pulls
at a lot of different levels you have
the local regulators and as anybody
who's been to China recently knows you
the auto pollution has become so intense
that sometimes you step out on the
street and begin coughing and you can't
see the tops of the buildings in
Shanghai from day to day so it's you
know how they how they work out managing
this is is really a huge task but
I think they'll find a way to meet them
a Toyota rushed in to build a Prius
plant there for example when I hear some
Chinese officials talking about 2100 and
Chinese introduced their renewable
standards a month after the Chinese
Institute said Peak Oil in 2012 I think
Peak Oil is very important as a
political concept it's the distribution
of oil reserves is becoming more and
more concentrated in the Middle East and
in certain large producers like Russia
or Venezuela the sort of non OPEC oil is
becoming harder to find more expensive
to go after and somewhat rare you know
it's there are a lot of estimates on
Peak Oil and I'm not really sure when
they are I've talked to a lot of people
there's no doubt that that at some point
in this century it's going to taper off
you know it's going to start on a down
slope but whether that occurs with the
kind of one of the elements of Peak Oil
theory is that they're sort of a big
cataclysmic shock and one day we wake up
in the world is different or one month
we wake up and it's not clear that
that's that that's going to happen it's
certainly something that could be
managed my sense is that the political
ramifications of the concentration of
oil reserves in certain countries are
really going to take precedence over
whether or not how much oil there is in
those reservoirs and the people issue is
actually going to be second at this
point in time to the ability for the
market as a whole to continue production
at the level we're demanding whether
we're talking pipelines whether we're
talking skilled workers out on the oil
fields whether we're talking the ability
to transport all
kinds of products in many different ways
the market is so constrained right now
that I think that is where the immediate
problem is with oil in terms of physical
quantities to be able to be the process
and delivered the peak oil problem I
think is still something looming and I
think police's captured exactly right
more of a political issue than a reality
at this point in time with the market
constrained in many other dimensions
other are there questions I saw another
hand I thought where you can't store it
and you buy from the company store and
you use it right when you buy it it's we
think it'd be difficult to introduce new
products at the retail level especially
with it being an integrated industry
they make it they process it and you buy
it from them at their location do you
speak in your book or would you be able
to speak today to the idea of how you
wouldn't go about introducing new
alternatives to the market
one way of changing your upstream is
changing your downstream so it's sort of
difficult when you have such a
constrained nozzle at the end of the
market how do you get me up and all in
how do you get the different products in
have that when it is such a closed yeah
I think that's a really interesting
question I think that when we fantasize
about ethanol we think oh I'll pull up
to the pump and if I I'm feeling like it
that day or the prices are very high
I'll buy this nice corn fuel I think
that the reality of how that how people
purchase ethanol is very interesting
there's some recent studies that have
been done both a little bit in Canada a
little bit in Australia and a few in the
central us on how people purchase
ethanol how ethanol is priced when it's
actually at the pump 85 and how yeah
those two things one thing is is that
you know ethanol has 30 percent really
85 will have about 30 percent less
energy a gallon of it will have 30
percent less energy than a gallon or 25
percent
than a gallon of equivalent gasoline so
you have mathematically challenged
American consumers needing to make this
quick this quick calculation about
whether or not their their purchase of
ethanol makes sense and what we know is
that they tend to buy they're more
likely to buy ethanol when the price
spread is bigger so they by ethanol
partly at the pump partly out of revenge
because people feel quite helpless when
they go to the gas pump and one of the
gas pump designers who I talked to said
well we the oil companies spend a lot of
time trying to kind of make that anger
dissipate that anger by making the pumps
very cute making modeling the money TMS
so anyway people go to the gas pump with
this attitude they're more likely to buy
ethanol if the price is cheaper the
problem is is that when you have
substitutable fuels the ethanol is
always going to be priced within a few
within with very little margin on the
gasoline so when you actually start
delivering ethanol to the pumps you may
find that people are not buying it
because it doesn't convert it doesn't
meet their expectations of what they
consider a bargain that's going to be
one complication if I were doing it I
would probably do which I'm not
obviously setting the policy I would do
a renewable energy standard I think so
that you would create kind of small
markets of people competing for the
business of replacing say two percent of
gasoline with ethanol and that way you'd
have different kinds of ethanol or
substitutable fuels competing and
gradually raise that resource standard
so that there as the competition grew
rather than subsidizing huge amounts of
ethanol and sticking them in very
expensive pumps and tanks across the
Midwest
hydrogen is so expensive to produce and
so expensive to install I see that
hydrogen hydrogen could work for it
could work in certain zones for example
cities or airports or you could
potentially have your Western and
Eastern trucking corridors running on
natural gas or compressed natural gas
which would give you you would have the
natural gas in the port you would have
the trucks coming out and and all those
main roads to their Depot's would be
outfitted with compressed natural gas
and then you could potentially switch
that to hydrogen later on but this is
all very like very far in the future and
very far from what we're thinking about
at this point but I can't imagine just
switching in hydrogen that will be you
need to somehow create a market where
there's some competition you can't just
say we'll take that hydrogen car and
that hydrogen car and the rest of you
yeah yes for this number of 1.07 cars
per American doesn't if you would
comment a little bit more on that in
terms of is that something that's kind
of out of structural necessity to our
economy that people need their cars to
commute and to move around or is that
really more a figure that relates to
cars being such an important part of
American culture I think it's both and
and it's interesting that people have
you know more than one car per
registered driver the number of families
with more than one car has risen
dramatically since the 70s the number of
families with more than four cars has
has risen even more dramatically and
it's you know kind of amazing you just
think of this a house dwarfed by the
cars parked out front it's part of our
culture but it also could be used in a
positive way to change the amount of
energy that we use if people have more
than one car then they can have a big
car that they use for family outings and
a small car that's used for commuting
and that's a good thing that means that
we could you know people people can can
continue their lifestyle but make
changes where it saves the most fuel
responsive price group and I was
wondering if you were speaking
specifically about Americans and also if
that was sort of part of the equation
that people don't really have a
transportation option so regardless of
price they still have to drive right and
I thought that I had also read it
there's a huge shift for fishing cars
when the price is really that they're
people in here or so ago and that's sort
of like American cars aren't doing so
well Bethenny's cards from surly solid
to me and oh okay
responding to price yeah it's partly has
to do with our dependence on our cars to
get to work and it partly has to do with
people that for about sixty percent of
Americans the price of gasoline doesn't
really affect their daily life the cost
of gasoline as the part of percentage of
cost of owning a car has actually fallen
since the 70s so it doesn't actually
affect them that much and they're free
to to use as much they also they make up
in other parts of their life people who
are poor make up they they buy more
cereal on sale and other things have
been some studies done by grocery stores
about that refresh me on your next
question that came off of it right well
maybe they don't actually drive less but
weren't they buying or cussing
okay right right by the end of 2006 it
didn't look like the actual fleet
mileage or miles per gallon had risen
that much in fact what had changed by
the end of 2006 was that the
acceleration time had speeded up in the
overall buying patterns even if you look
at some of the figures people still
continue to buy the very large pickup
trucks the part of it is that the auto
industry stepped in by giving people
rebates on gas for the next two years or
the next year I can't remember whether
it was one or two years of gas with the
price kind of frozen so that they were
able to move those trucks off the lot
and so I don't believe that the actual
fleet efficiency changed or changed for
the better after all those high prices
definitely some people are buying much
smaller cars there is a response but
it's very small so for example you might
say a 10% increase in price might gets
you less than 1% change in your driving
behavior may need and a half a percent
so it's a very small response that
you're seeing but it's largely offset by
income in other words we have more
income that really dictates a lot more
of our behavior than price does right
now although in times of shock when in
this country if you track you see price
changes like in the 70s or in the late
70s you've seen people respond prices
much more quickly but as price comes
back down and income goes back up
they'll respond to price but only a very
little bit so I think what Lisa said is
right
but you also have to remember that we
are our country on something like 225
million cars and we sell something like
16 or 17 million a year so we have just
a very small fraction 16 or 17 million
becomes more efficient cars compared to
the existing stock in the economy it has
a very small impact
we take a very long time for it to be
really seen in a pronounced way there is
a response but it's very small and the
other thing that's interesting is that
in Europe the government actually they
don't have fuel efficiency standards you
know the taxes on gas are about five
times what they are here so you feel it
more at the pump but people were not
actually buying more efficient cars and
the car manufacturers were not initially
making more efficient cars that the
government encouraged them you know as
more Europeans start buying the cars the
government encouraged the car
manufacturers to sort of set up a system
to voluntarily increase the fuel
efficiency of their cars foreign cars no
American cars and I think that's one of
the messages is that we need to pay
attention to is and you mentioned this
in terms of China - they took a look at
the response in Detroit Detroit
bad-mouth miles per gallon cafe
standards and China saw it as a huge
opportunity and I think there are a
number of places along line where we're
missing some important strategic
opportunities that may come back to
haunt us but the other interesting thing
about the report he's mentioning is that
many of the least efficient cars also
came from Europe anyway yes my sense is
that American automakers just don't get
it they're not figuring out that people
are looking for you know efficiency and
quality and you wash an American car
commercial and they don't tell you a
whole lot about the car you know you
might hear some cool music and see some
you know young people having fun but the
American automakers ii mean look what's
happening to ford right now as you stun
as you looked into this whole thing is
your sense that their American auto
industry is a dinosaur that
can't recover or if you see any youth
and new ideas in Detroit that can save
them hmm I haven't been hanging out in
Detroit um but I did talk to some of the
people I spent a fair amount of time
with some of the people in GM's sort of
new and alternative fuels division but
to sort of step back from your question
you know Detroit does a really good job
of giving Americans what they say they
want and there were some follow-up
studies done I think in 1995 of car
buyers and and they get a huge sample I
mean they it's a it's Moritz Marketing
follows up on almost everyone who buys a
car they found that four percent this is
2000 2005 prices had already been rising
considerably it was before the Katrina
shock but prices had already risen by
about I don't know significantly just
four percent of people said that fuel
efficiency was their most important
consideration when buying a car and a
much higher percentage is much more
concerned about the Sun literally
concerned about the size of the
cupholders I mean that really affects
their comfort so I don't think that we
can necessarily say that that the
automakers are our old dinosaurs I think
that they they see what they see rather
than necessarily what what we want to
think about ourselves which is that we
buy fuel rationally and I don't think we
buy it particularly rationally we just
consider it kind of a something that
happens you know we buy the fuel and if
the fuel is too expensive a lot of
people buy it on credit cards and kind
of absorb the price fluctuations over
the long term and pay a lot of interest
on them I do think that they I think
that the industry I think regulation at
this point would really help I think
when you think about the car it's so
inefficient only about 13% of the energy
is used to actually haul the person
along and they're not very efficient one
of the things that's amazing about the
car is that you when you want to go
faster you press on the gas and so you
give it more gas well when you think
about how the rest of our equipment
works that's a very old know
of how things should work a more
efficient engine would turn at a regular
at its most efficient speed at a
constant amount of fuel and then the car
itself would configure itself around
that speed to go faster to go slower to
go with more power and so I think we
need to start asking ourselves whether
focusing so much so much of our policy
on energy supply has not left us with
slightly worse cars than we would have
if we had had a better balance between
demand and supply we just need to think
about whether we are sort of
prioritizing very cheap solutions to
mobility yes
Iran and Russia most of them are not
very friendly to the US you see so we're
more openness to this country because
he's coming what I need is more
investment to try to increase their
production of oil right well it's very
hard to get Venezuela for example to
agree to accept foreign investment
they've the issues have to do with
nationalism in those countries and
whether or not they want to allow for an
investment and I think that it's hard
for the u.s. to Co along insisting that
people expect except for an investment
at this point but I also think that
there's sort of a new political wind
blowing in some of the oil producers in
which nationalism that's quite necessary
their resource nationalism is really
necessary because as a country it's very
difficult to deliver profits from oil to
the population and yet the population
has very high expectations and so one of
the things that you can deliver is a lot
of nationalist rhetoric and which
involves anti-american rhetoric and I
think I think Chavez is really good at
that so you can do a lot of things
politically with the oil that you
actually can't do economically and I
think that the US needs to change its
energy policy to recognize that and try
to use that to its advantage whether
that means investing
we tend to want to only invest in oil
projects in oil-producing countries but
we might start to this again is very
sort of pie in the sky but you might
consider for example taxing imported oil
at a fairly small rate per barrel and
using that as an investment back into
certain oil producing countries to
create jobs or to create infrastructure
there why 70 acres much more incentive
and we're developing higher efficiency
cars shorts man versus
just seems like they were driven more to
come up with more fuel-efficient cars
then they were now
well they were driven by really strict
cafe standards that started and they
were also driven by a huge shock I mean
people really reduce the amount that
they drove they were really looking
around for other types of vehicles but
there's a great book by David Halverson
I think it's called the reckoning yeah
the reckoning that chronicles how the
auto industry did not believe that there
could be a fuel shortage or fuel shock
in the early 70s and so they were really
caught flat-footed a difference between
now and we have people more willing to
take
being able to 1870s who had people
waiting in line at the tank there were
because of short shortages real or not
alternate days of when you could buy
fuel and you had a presidential
leadership that was saying this is a
national crisis do something about it
right there are different environment
that are not directly I think that
actually when when prices really started
going up in 2005 if there had been a
different government response what we
had was in in 2005 was essentially a
message to people that oh my god
gas prices are high they shouldn't be we
need to have lessen the environmental
regulations or allow different boutique
non boutique fuels in different areas we
need to somehow reduce the prices or we
need to somehow punish the oil companies
instead of a responsive Wow you should
really start to conserve I mean Nixon in
his sort of depressing fashion said that
the White House Christmas tree would
have to be unplugged it took that in
1973 but you know that sent a really
powerful message and it was something
that people could understand and say oh
okay we should we should be actually
actively taking action I remember that
year that people didn't put up Christmas
lights and it wasn't just because of the
price it was because you had set a norm
of behavior and I think one of the
issues now is that we we sort of our
approach towards energy policy has been
well you can have your cake and eat it
too and you don't have to conserve and
we're not going to tell you anything and
eventually you'll start conserving when
prices get high enough but where that
really hurts poor people it really hurts
people in Wyoming who drive 18,000 miles
per capita per year you know people in
Washington Drive a little more than
6-thousand and so you can understand how
that would be affecting people in rural
cold states people don't realize that
efficiency has since the seventies since
the oil all right so the density for is
actually provided about three-quarters
of all of our new energy demand where as
supply has provided on one-quarter but
efficiency is the energy we don't use so
we don't see it and we automatically
gravitate towards the supply side and a
perfect example
with the current administration's
announcement of the Strategic Petroleum
Reserve the president's announcement he
proposes to double the capacity of the
reserve from 700 million barrels to 14
1.4 billion and I did a calculation and
Lisa and I've talked about this that if
we've taken the 65 billion dollars
instead of putting a new capacity put it
into efficiency we might get about five
times more in the way of efficiency
savings and we'd have stored in that
reserve but we never think about that as
an option it's it's a different way of
thinking we're gonna have to redirect
our understanding and resources how they
might flow to a better benefit